mein name ist professor dr hendrik
strikt ich bin der leiter des instituts
für virologie am universitätsklinikum
bonn
wir forschen hier an vielen
verschiedenen viren aber derzeit nur an
saas kopf zwei dem neuen kona virus was
wir hier machen es nicht nur dass wir
uns dass wir selber anschauen sondern
auch nach heinsberg gefahren sind um
symptome zu erfragen und das virus auch
von den klinischen symptomen besser zu
verstehen
ein bereich den wir dort festgestellt
haben zum beispiel ist dass viele der
infizierten berichten dass sie
geschmacks und geruchs verlust für
einige zeit haben was vorher noch nie
festgestellt worden waren
also
lars koch 2 virus gehört zur gruppe oder
familie der korona führung wir kennen
mehrere coronaviren die für den menschen
gefährlich sein können oder den menschen
infizieren
wir haben heimisch bei uns jedes jahr
wir sagen dazu endemisch vier
coronaviren die immer wieder solche
globalen entdeckte machen
die sind jetzt nicht per se gefährlich
aber coronaviren generell können vor
allem älteren menschen oder menschen die
vorerkrankung haben wirklich zu setzen
und dort auch gefährlich sein
also das neue corona virus ist sehr
infektiös und kann sehr schnell von
mensch zu menschen springen dadurch
können eben sehr schnell auch alte
menschen oder menschen mit
vorerkrankungen davon betroffen seien
und bei denen kann es eben gefährlich
sein weil es dann eine schwere
lungenentzündung geben kann
mit atemnot und sogar atemstillstand
das können wir noch gar nicht sagen ob
die ansteckung wahrscheinlichkeit höher
oder niedriger im sommer ist ich finde
aber es gibt ein paar hinweise dafür
dass wir vielleicht ein wenig
erleichterung im sommer sehen werden zum
einen ist unser verhalten im sommer
anders als im winter wir gehen mehr in
die breite wir gehen mehr auseinander
wir sitzen nicht mehr gemeinsam in engen
räumen
in engen u bahn wir haben auch keine
heizungsluft mehr die schädlich für die
schleimhäute sind und auch die sonne hat
einen positiven einfluss auf das
immunsystem
was hinzukommt ist wenn wir einfach mal
einen blick auf die südliche halbkugel
werfen
wir haben derzeit in asien in europa und
nordamerika wirklich große
ballungsgebiete von infektionen wenn wir
aber auch die südliche halbkugel schauen
also in süd amerika oder südamerika oder
in südafrika da sehen wir nur
vereinzelte infektionen so dass es uns
zumindest derzeit ein bisschen hoffnung
gibt dass wir zum sommer einen spannung
sehen werden
da wissen wir wie das virus übertragen
wird das virus springt war sie vom
rachen zu rachen beim bei der
unterhaltung oder beim husten und niesen
je mehr man voneinander entfernt ist
desto weniger desto geringer ist eben
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich
infiziert so ein social distanz ihn wird
eigentlich auch praktiziert für grippe
infektionen und ist ein gutes mittel im
krankenhaus dass das jetzt in so einer
großen weise in ganz deutschland
versuchten ist neu aber ich bin auch
überzeugt dass das uns erleichterung
bringen wird die zahlen in italien sind
beunruhigend aber man muss sich auch
anschauen wer dort getestet wurde
wir wissen dass zu anfangs nur die auf
saas koch 2 getestet wurden die eben ins
krankenhaus gekommen sind also die schon
mit schwerer atemnot ins krankenhaus
gekommen sind oder sogar in einigen
fällen wurden die toten im nachhinein
getestet die sterberate setzt sich ja
zusammen nicht nur aus der anzahl der
gestorbenen sondern auch aus der anzahl
die infiziert sind und wir nehmen an
dass wissen wir aber noch nicht genau
wir nehmen an dass diese dunkelziffer
also die anzahl der infizierten in in
italien sehr viel höher ist und wir
deswegen so eine hohe rate sehen das
kann ich seriös überhaupt nicht
beantworten wenn wir einen impfstoff
haben werden
wir können natürlich sehr schnell einen
impfstoff konstrukt erstellen also einen
kandidaten einen impfstoffkandidaten
generieren
letztendlich ob der impfstoffkandidat
auch funktioniert also dieser konstrukt
dann auch wirklich eine schützende
immunität also von neuen infektionen
schützen kann
das kann man erst sehen wenn man das am
menschen getestet hat und das kann sehr
schnell gehen also wirklich in 18
monaten dass dieser impfstoff wirkt und
dann auch im großen stil produziert wird
aber wir kennen das von anderen lehrern
dass das jahrzehnten dauern kann
denken wir an epstein barr virus
infektion cmv hepatitis b hepatitis c
oder hiv infektion da können dekaden
verkehr
ich glaube
massives testen oder aggressives testen
ist ein guter weg um die pandemie
einzudämmen und ich glaube dass wir auch
eine gute strategie für deutschland
wir haben einen mangel an ressourcen
hier wie uns fehlt die chemie also die
reagenzien die es braucht um diese tests
durchzuführen
aber jetzt sind wir biologen gefragt und
jetzt sind die diagnostika und
labormediziner gefragt dass wir kreativ
werden und vielleicht neue wege gehen
ich kann nicht seriös beantworten ob es
realistischer ist ein impfstoff zu
finden oder ein medikament zu haben
wir haben natürlich im labor weltweit
viele wirkstoffe gegen lars koch 2
gefunden
das ist aber in labor schade also in der
petrischale quasi herausgefunden worden
dass bestimmte wirkstoffe die es gibt
bereits dass die gegen saas koch 2
wirken
das heißt aber leider nicht dass diese
wirkstoffe auch im menschen
funktionieren werden das hängt eben auch
damit zu davon ab wie gut der wirkstoff
penetriert durch das gewebe also
durchsickert durch das gewebe und dann
zum zielort angelangt genauso ist es
beim impfstoff man kann natürlich eine
ein impfstoffkandidat finden und
kreieren aber ob der am ende
funktioniert kann man nicht vorhersagen
das ist eine sehr schwierige frage und
auch nicht wirklich eindeutig zu
beantworten was wir natürlich sehen ist
dass die die sowieso schon extreme
vorerkrankungen haben und sehr alt sind
dass die weil eine höhere
wahrscheinlichkeit haben am saß kopf
zwei auch zu versterben
aber ob es jetzt eine höhere sterberate
geben wird weltweit aufgrund dieses
erregers kann sein muss aber auch nicht
sein das können wir leider erst am ende
der pandemie beantworten